i couldn't believe this until i read it
in the notes but this is your first uh
official horror movie zach so i was just
making me wonder have you ever
considered doing a horror movie before
and if you have what is it about this
fire starter movie that made it
different to you and worth committing to
i love the genre i've always wanted to
do one um but i think the
there were several cool elements i mean
hey this is stephen king but then also
keith thomas the director he did a great
film called the vigil that i saw several
years ago and i've just been a fan of
his ever since and uh i thought this was
a really really great story it's the
inception of kind of a superhero coming
into her own and i just want to say you
were amazing in it thank you you too
we crushed it it was pretty cool she was
a great first daughter for me to have
she's awesome even with all your
experience it does make me wonder is
there anything about what it takes to
tell a horror story that kind of
surprised you and maybe even gave you i
guess like a new tool in your acting
toolkit so to speak that you could apply
if you do future horror movies you know
i
there's there's this quality that uh
that that once again keith was able to
sort of uh
bring to the material and that is this
this kind of really grounded uh element
but at the core of it this is a story
about family and about kind of growing
up and the challenges of growing up and
and i i always gravitate towards those
real
real emotions our real human experience
so so i don't know the
the all these sort of supernatural
horror elements were kind of an
afterthought when you really are just a
guy trying to protect your daughter or
daughter trying to protect your dad yeah
i mean two best things coming together
you know you have the superpower and
also the family basis and um right
tis fair points it's the family that's
the core of this story and it's always
been why it is one of my favorite
stephen king stories but i'm also genre
obsessed so i'm going to keep harping on
that ryan you're in a different
situation here where you do know a thing
or two about working on horror projects
so is there anything you learn while
making you know things like a chapter 2
or american horror story that you were
able to use on fire starter it's so
strange jorge has just kind of always
followed me i don't know it always has
um
but
firestarter although is different than
any other horror to me um from what i
find and because it's not only
is it horror but it's also this family
like we were talking about it not only
that it's just
it's
it's so it's it's about family bottom
line and that's something you don't see
in horror often and that's why i feel
like people
need to watch this because it's not only
horror but it's also about family two
best things coming together so
um it's so different and unique from any
other horror and we avoided clowns
i i'm now so terrified from clowns but i
thought you might be scarred from that i
was everybody got me
well now you're making me glad that i
didn't put a pennywise somewhere behind
me because they're lurking around this
room somewhere i feel like they sneak up
on you they might just
sneak up on us
all right to wrap up here ryan i wanted
to ask you about your experience working
with zach is there anything you saw him
do on set while making fire started that
maybe made you think i like that idea or
that technique and i want to try it on
my next movie well you know what he was
very very giving and very present and
very real in the moment
and it's amazing to work off of someone
that's doing that and it's honestly very
fascinating to watch
um on youtube
i don't know how it's crazy
you're so young it's so professional
you're so talented i got that
i got that same vibe from you you made
me go like oh i need to get on my game
oh you did the same to me so i guess i
guess it just worked out for the better
good all right
you too my heart i love it big
congratulations on the movie
all right thank you